There was a very interesting shift that, uh,
happened right at the end of 2019, which I
believe is now going to dictate a lot of the
narrative around the 2020 primary, uh, for
the first quarter of 2020, certainly into
and through the first few primaries.
And the shift is that both democratic party
insiders and even some in corporate media
seem to have had like a light bulb go off
where they realized, wait a second, Bernie
Sanders might actually win the democratic
nomination.
Now this is not an analysis of whether Bernie
could be Trump.
We've done that analysis.
That's a separate story.
This is not an analysis of Bernie's policy.
This is not an analysis of whether Bernie
Sanders is a communist.
He's not a, we've done those analyses.
This is about something else.
We've talked about the Bernie blackout that
took place during much of 2019 in terms of
covering Bernie Sanders campaign in a serious
manner by corporate media.
And we've also talked about the attitude of
some in the DNC that Bernie simply can't win.
Others on the other hand, believed that Bernie
could win and were scared.
So they were meeting about how to try to stop
Bernie.
Famously, Pete Buddha judge was even included
in some of those early stop Bernie, uh, sort
of meetings, um, that, uh, were, were taking
place about how can we make sure that we deny
Bernie Sanders the nomination.
But in the last few weeks of 2019 things changed.
We'll talk about the fundraising piece in
a little bit.
Um, but a few other things went on.
Number one.
Part of it was Elizabeth Warren's collapse
in the polls and she had nearly tied to Joe
Biden for first place in the democratic primary
a few months ago.
She has been on the decline since then.
She's dropped to third place.
She's lost almost half of her support from
her peak a few months ago, much more solidly
behind Bernie, more than four points behind
as of this morning.
Now, another part of it is not just Elizabeth
Warren's decline.
What we've seen if you look at polling, is
that many candidates were up and down and
sometimes eventually out.
Uh, while Bernie Sanders on the other hand
has basically been steady for months and months
other than some very small shifts.
So think back, Biden had that huge spike when
he formally announced up to 40%.
Then he dropped, he leveled out every debate.
He seems to lose some support because his
performances have been by and large, terrible.
And then gained some of it back very erratic.
Okay.
Uh, Elizabeth Warren climbed, as I mentioned,
all the way up to almost hi Joe Biden.
We really within the margin of error to tie
Joe Biden and then just started sinking, losing
almost half of her support.
Camilla Harris, she climbed all the way up
to 15 after one debate in which she had one
of these kill shots against a, excuse me punching
my microphone against Joe Biden, but then
she Relic relatively quickly fell.
She ended her campaign a couple of weeks ago
as we told you who Leon Castro
just announced that he's ending his campaign.
P booted judge had an upswing, didn't really
seem believable, uh, to many people and he
has settled back down basically to where he
was.
And this entire time Bernie Sanders has been
holding steady, even his heart attack, only
a relatively small bump.
Now there's two ways to interpret that and
I have no interest in, uh, uh, pulling the
wool over your eyes.
One way to interpret that is that Bernie Sanders
has a very solid base of support from which
to build.
And now the question is how does he build
it and we'll talk about that.
The other way to think about this is that
Bernie has basically maxed out that Bernie
has hit his ceiling and barring some very
unlikely circumstances.
It's great for Bernie that he's held roughly
the same level of support for awhile, but
he's incapable of growing that support.
Those are two different opinions about this
and we'll talk about that now.
Just before the new year, you saw democratic
officials, party operatives, pundits, all
starting to take Bernie Sanders more seriously.
David Brock is a big democratic insider.
He's, he was a Hillary Clinton ally in 2016
he ran a pro Hillary pack in 2016 I was on
a panel with him at Politiken back in 2018
he said, quote, it may have been inevitable
that eventually you would have two candidates
representing each side of the ideological
divide in the party.
A lot of smart people I've talked to lately
think there's a very good chance these two
ended up being Biden and Sanders Sanders.
Now, there is no denying that Bernie Sanders
is solidly not in first place.
The more I look into things, the more I believe
the polls about Joe Biden and that Joe Biden
is solidly in first place.
I know that there are a lot of people in my
audience who don't want to acknowledge that.
Uh, what I have been increasingly realizing
and a call we got last week or earlier this
week actually solidified that some of us are
so enmeshed in online politics where we say,
where are these Biden supporters?
I'm not coming across any of these Biden's
supporters.
It feels like we rarely come across them.
Remember that call I got explaining for a
viewer explain that at Christmas, uh, all
of their relatives are completely in for Biden.
They are not voters that are part of the online
world that we exist in.
And I believe this applies to millions of
Americans.
So I do believe Joe Biden is in first place.
I am increasingly thinking about how could
the Bernie Warren support be consolidated
because I do believe that if it could, Joe
Biden would no longer be the front runner,
but we'll be talking more about that as far
as today's conversation.
Bernie Sanders solidly in second place being
taken more and more seriously by the establishment
and by corporate media.
The question now is what can push Bernie Sanders
over the top?
If anything?
It seems as though Elizabeth Warren going
by the polls does not have what it takes to
go the distance, her support or eroding by
almost 50% over the last few months.
The debates aren't going to help Bernie.
I mean it just, we've had a bunch now it's
not moving Bernie support.
I know that I still have people in my audience
who say, David, at the next debate, if Bernie
does X, if Bernie does Y, he will take support
from Biden, Warren, whoever.
It's not going to happen in that way unless
someone seriously blunders during an upcoming
debate, someone who has significant support
being Biden, Warren, maybe Buddha, judge,
uh, but the further in you get, the less debates
move the needle.
Unless someone really blunders, there is a
bigger chance that Bernie blunders and loses
support.
Then there is that in the debates.
Bernie overtakes Joe Biden.
That's not about Bernie.
Okay.
Understand that this is just the way the debate
debates work.
The further end you get, the more candidates
are known, the more their positions are known.
The the smaller, the possibility of making
large gains from the debates becomes so it
becomes a mathematical question.
It's also a political question.
How can support move to Bernie if that's where
you want to see the support move?
What can you do?
I don't know the answer.
Warren falling doesn't seem to help.
She's lost almost half her support in the
last few months and Bernie's basically even
let me know your thoughts.
What could change the balance towards Bernie
from where we are today?
A big piece of evaluating how a candidate
is doing is fundraising and our current system,
and I want to talk about that next